madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
l'attentât contre les installations de
la télévision en mayenne la fin à
versailles du congrès pour l'europe la
convention pour l'europe monsieur
raymond barre vient de prononcer le
discours de clôture
et puis la 13e journée du championnat de
france de football et le retour de nice
à la première place du classement
voilà les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce dimanche 23 octobre
auparavant et avant de passer donc à
cette actualité je voudrais vous
présenter nos invités ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
vous les connaissez tous ou du moins
vous connaissez tous leurs noms claire
bretécher druillet losier et reiser vous
l'avez compris quatre dessinateurs
humoristiques qui font les beaux jours
de la bande dessinée française en ce
moment nous les retrouverons à la fin de
ce journal à propos de la convention de
la bande dessinée qui se tient en ce
moment même à paris et depuis hier
voyons maintenant donc l'actualité de
cette journée plusieurs centaines de
milliers de français sont privés depuis
hier soir 22h à peu près de télévision
un attentat à l'explosif a en effet
détruit cette nuit là stations de relais
hertzien de pré-en-pail dans la mayenne
cette station servait de relais à la
télévision 1ère 2ème et 3ème chaîne
ainsi qu'à la radio en modulation de
fréquence pour une bonne partie de la
normandie dont cherbourg et une partie
de la bretagne dont rennes
personne n'a été blessé par cette
explosion mais les dégâts sont très
importants
il atteindrait environ 10 millions de
francs
c'est par une lettre arrivée en début de
matinée l afp de rennes que l'attentât
de pré-en-pail a été revendiquée
[ __ ] art déclare la résistance
nationaliste bretonne prouve sa
détermination à poursuivre la lutte pour
la souveraineté du peuple breton et de
la nation bretonne
vive la dépendance fin de citation
en attendant les dégâts sont très
importants la forte charge de plastique
sont le tilt un débat c'est l'antenne et
toucher les bâtiments qui commande les
émetteurs de la région
s'il est difficile et délicat de
préciser pour l'instant les retombées
exactes de cet attentat il semble bien
que les mouvements extrémistes aille
vers une radicalisation de leur moyen
d'action
l'agitation anti allemande à paris dans
la nuit de vendredi à samedi ne s'est
pas poursuivie hier et cette nuit le
calme a régné en effet aussi bien dans
la capitale que dans les grandes
métropoles provincial deux exceptions
toutefois noté deux attentats à paris
contre des sociétés allemandes des
dégâts mais pas de blessés sur le plan
de l'anc est consécutive à la découverte
du corps de mathieu martin flyers à
mulhouse
aucun élément nouveau n'est intervenu
alors qu'il faille en ce domaine être
prudent la police française mène ses
investigations dans le plus grand secret
les journalistes ne sont pas justement
dans le secret de la police sur le plan
politique en france les partis
s'installe depuis pas mal de temps déjà
dans une précampagne électorale
particulièrement active on fignole vous
le savez les listes de candidature pour
les prochaines élections législatives de
mars 78 et les leaders politiques
poursuivent leur tour de france 2000
thing en manifestation ainsi monsieur
chirac parlera ce soir à paris mardi à
avignon mercredi a dit jeudi à gap
monsieur marchait prononcera un discours
a lancé comme très important à vitry sur
marne jeudi et monsieur mitterrand
pendant sera lui dimanche prochain le
discours de clôture du congrès annuel
des élus socialistes et républicains à
villeurbanne sans attendre ce discours
le leader socialiste a d'ailleurs fait
le point de la situation à gauche dix
ans en accordant une interview au
journal du dimanche d'aujourd'hui une
phrase est à retenir dans cette
interview
après les élections de mars affirme
monsieur françois mitterrand le parti
socialiste apparaîtra comme la force
politique dominante pour les années à
venir
monsieur raymond barre lui a pris la
parole il ya quelques minutes à
versailles le premier ministre
s'adressait aux participants à la
convention de l'europe
au cours de deux jours de débats et
c'est à versailles l'organisation
française du mouvement européen a donné
le point de départ d'une campagne
destinée à sensibiliser l'opinion à la
veille de la première élection au
suffrage direct du parlement européenne
pendant cette convention pour l'europe
on a débattu des moyens pour développer
sur le plan politique économique
culturel l'europe pour atteindre les
états unis durant de nombreuses
personnalités tant françaises
qu'européennes ont participé à cette
convention dont le premier ministre
raymond barre qui a prononcé le discours
de clôture
l'europe est à la croisée des chemins
parce que le monde est en profonde
mutation
et parce que la communauté l'aide aussi
dans ce monde en profonde mutation
il faudrait un fatal aveuglement pour ne
point voir que la communauté est à tous
un dispense indispensable d'abord à ses
états membres isolés ceux ci seraient
sans doute tentés mortels facilitée par
le repli sur eux-mêmes et par le
protectionnisme
ce serait une absurdité puisque le
propre de nos pays et d'être avant toute
chose des économies de transformation
important des matières premières et
exportant des produits finis le
repliement signifierait pour chacun
d'entre eux l' asphyxie progressive
indispensable ensuite aux partenaires
industrialisés de la communauté les pays
développés sont les uns pour les autres
les meilleurs clients de leurs
concertations loyal et 3 tu peux tu es
doit naître la confiance en l'avenir
or c'est de cette confiance dont les
agents économiques ont aujourd'hui plus
que toute autre chose besoin c'est de
cette confiance en l'avenir
dire que nos peuples ont besoin l'europe
comme le monde est en profonde mutation
et cela risque d'entraîner une plus
grande difficulté à maintenir le strict
respect des obligations communautaires
je n'entends certes pas distribuer les
loges le blâme chaque état membre a ses
propres intérêts et ses propres
difficultés
ce que je voudrais simplement mais avec
gravité souligné
c'est qu'il est fondamental pour
l'avenir la construction européenne et
par conséquent pour celui de n'obéit de
ne point céder à la tentation d'accepter
d'exception l'exception de renégociation
compromis la remise en cause subreptice
et inavoués des bases même de l'édifice
que nous sommes engagés à construire
ensemble de l'étranger deux brèves
nouvelles d'après le président jimmy
carter un nouvel accord sur la
limitation des armes stratégiques
pourrait être conclu dans quelques
semaines entre moscou et washington
un optimisme américains qui étaient dans
la soirée un peu tempérée par une
certaine prudence soviétique monsieur
brejnev hier soir en effet uniquement
parler de légers progrès dans la
négociation la politique française en
matière d'immigration été condamné hier
à alger par les syndicats arabes et
africains qui tenait réunion
cette politique qui concernent en
particulier la famille des travailleurs
immigrés ne sera peut-être d'ailleurs
pas adopté dans sa présentation actuelle
la section sociale du conseil d'état l'a
jugé en effet a jugé en effet
défavorablement le texte gouvernemental
annoncé en sport avec la 13e journée de
championnat de france de football qui
s'est déroulé hier soir sur toute la
france et qui a modifié le classement
nice a en effet repris la tête de ce
classement après la défaite sans appel 3
but à 0 de monaco devant 3 les
footballeurs hier soir ont d'ailleurs
été généreux 31 buts ont été marqués le
score le plus important de cette soirée
de football celui qui s'est joué à lyon
lyon marseille 4 buts à 2 pour lyon
match attendu en effet entre l'équipe
lyonnaise en rouge une équipe
convalescente remise en selle par une
victoire à bordeaux la semaine dernière
l'équipe de l'olympique de marseille
version skoblar marque ovi qui reste sur
toute une série de bons résultats
les premières minutes étaient équilibrés
avec des actions de part et d'autre
quant à la 22e minute sur une action de
gally celui ci dans la surface de
réparation était fauché par bracci l'
arbitre monsieur ventraux indiquait le
point de penalty
penalty tiré sans coup férir par lacombe
alors que migeon étaient partis avant le
départ du ballon
l'arbitré validait le but 1 1 0 ce but
allait décontractée une équipe de lyon
offensives en première mi-temps qui sur
cette action allait marquer un nouveau
but grâce à une bonne remise de la tête
de spiegel et un tir en pleine course de
bernard lacombe qui livré un match dans
le match à son rival pour le poste
d'avant centre de l'équipe de france
flammes le marseillais marc berdoll
boubacar réduisait bien la marque sur un
bon tir peu après la demi heure de jeu
mais juste avant la mi temps sur un coup
franc généreusement accordé par
l'arbitré monsieur votre au spiegel
allait placer la balle dans le mur de
marseille malheureux migeon complètement
pris à contre 3 à 1 à la mi temps
la deuxième mi temps allait être plus
équilibré monsieur votre au sifflet est
un nouveau penalty faute de sewen
cassure spiegel et c'était encore
bernard lacombe qui était chargé de le
tirer
il marquait une première fois mais le
gardien ayant bougé monsieur vautrot
faisait recommencer le penalty il avait
tiré deux fois sur la droite du gardien
lacombe une troisième et non le
contre-pied total là encore 4,1 trésor
avait pour marquer un joli but à 11
minutes de la fin c'en était fait des
chances marseillaise une victoire
importante sans doute pour l'avenir de
l'olympique lyonnais
une victoire obtenue par 4 buts à 2 sur
une bonne équipe marseille
ennis a donc repris la tête du
championnat
des professeurs qui font rire sans le
vouloir je crois que cela a toujours
existé dans l'université française mais
un brillant universitaire qui a pour
passion ne fait rire les enfants c'est
une exception en plus quand ce brillant
universitaire fait de cette passion son
second métier et qu'il y réussit à
l'égal des meilleurs professionnels
eh bien je crois que cela devient un
exploit à l'heure où certains déplorent
si souvent que l'université ne devrait
pas davantage sur l'extérieur et se
coupe trop souvent de l'asie d'autres et
celui là en particulier vous allez le
voir démontre le contraire
je suis maintenant maître assistant à
l'université de compiègne eh bien oui
j'espère je mène des recherches je suis
en train de terminer à doctorat d'état
je participe à des séminaires et si l'on
me disait un jour eh bien
vos recherches vous permettent d'avoir
une autre responsabilité un autre emploi
dans l'université
je n'accepterai avec plaisir si on me
disait vous resterez toute votre vie
maître assistant j'accepterai aussi une
gauthier 37 ans il enseigne à de futurs
ingénieurs l'expression et la
communication discipline groupé avec
d'autres dans la division de
développement général de la personnalité
à l'université de compiègne ce
professeur ce chercheur ce docteur est
flêtre exerce une seconde profession il
est clown auguste de cirque et j'avais
16 ans quand j'ai commencé à être clown
et depuis 20 ans avec le même partenaire
une chez pas des puces mesure à qui n'a
pas déplu chase us
mais à 20 ans je vous en ai dit que je
faisais le clown comme ça par amusement
par distraction et que dès que je serais
devenu un professeur sérieux je cesserai
de faire ça mais maintenant choix devant
vous pour vous elle va sauter demain un
desk gauche sûrement un desk droit
jadidi dont on dit un index
ben alors relations entre a sûrement
bush ma mère m'a dit une chose que j'ai
toujours gardé et qui est finalement le
fondement du métier c'est je me mets que
tu fasse rire mais je ne veux pas que tu
sois ridicule et le cloud n'est jamais
ridicule
le maquillage rarement mais très élaboré
le geste est très élaboré il ya tout un
tout un langage corporel et gestuelle
qui sont vraiment fouiller élaboré et
qu'il faut maîtriser
on
mais dis donc pour dire est que tu
reviens de la chasse pourquoi et
pourquoi pourquoi et regard de sa
annonce elle dénoncé par la shdm alors
questionné ksari c'est rien c'est un
souvenir d'hier soir à souvenirs hier
soir pourquoi souvenir hier soir j'étais
danser au bal de la police au pourquoi
lorsqu'on est bistouille lorsqu'on
exerce le beau et noble métier de clown
éprouvait le besoin d'être aussi
professeur d'université et ben ça doit
peut-être parce que on est clown tout le
temps et qu'on est clown aussi quand on
est professeur ou bien c'est peut-être
que
quand on est professeur on a autant de
plaisir que quand on est sur la scène
huit moment clé du procès et on vous les
présente isolément
je me vois très bien professeur en tant
qu'enseignant jusqu'à la retraite c'est
un peu comme si vous étiez au milieu et
que vous êtes attaqué de différent quand
je suis dans mon université soit avec
des étudiants en train de danser nier ou
en train de diriger leurs travaux soit
en train de mener mes propres recherches
je suis heureux
jamais je n'ai vu un un élève quand un
proviseur ou un étudiant maintenant
choqué pour les gens c'est une démarche
intéressante et qui suscite moins un
homme de la curiosité mais souvent une
curiosité sympathique ou merveille en
fait qu'ils soient clown lui a proposé
par un certain prestige sans souci
capable d'avoir des activités
extérieures importantes sont comme un
jeu des maîtres assistants qui ont des
hobbies très variés y il faut niveau de
la voile y en a qui font de la pêche à
la ligne mais qui vont aux canaries lui
il est clown après tout c'est un homme
très sérieux dont je suis très satisfait
vous embête pas un qui peut voir des
gens de l'extérieur venir vers le cirque
contraire entrée en contre exemple il en
faudrait plus il nous faudrait plus
jouer des heures
donner du renouveau oui parce qu'il a
certainement une conception différente
de ce qu'on peut avoir nous il viendra
sûrement avec des idées à guérande et un
autre neuf comme un neuf ensembles et
les barioz adoptent bistouille absolu de
tout coeur de tout perdre 8 bis ou de
moyen de m'exprimer je trouve un
équilibre les deux sont nécessaires
m
depuis hier se tient à paris la
convention internationale de la bd la
bande dessinée cette manifestation a
pour but comme toutes les réunions
d'ailleurs de réunir des gens est donc
classée il s'agit de dessinateurs et
d'éditeurs de bande dessinée une presse
qui lier en très bonne santé puisque si
l'on en croit les tirages et si on en
croit les sorties il sort en moyenne
parce que chaque semaine un nouveau
titre quatre de ces dessinateurs
humoristiques notre réalisatrice ou les
a montrés tout à l'heure au début de ce
journal nous ont rejoints dans ce studio
de cognac jay sont avec georges bigot
georges bigot vous pouvez nous présenter
vos invités oui je vous les présente
rapidement philippe druillet que vous
connaissez c'est le spécialiste ce
dessin qui n'en finit pas avec le côté
fantastique le côté futuriste losier
d'hommes lui plutôt dans la tranche de
vie et c'est le social c'est l'homme
qu'on voit un peu macho faut bien le
dire ou quelquefois dans des situations
de deux bonhommes suffisant et qui a
bien réussi dans la vie et qui a une
famille assez compliquée avec des
enfants qui ne vont pas toujours dans le
bon sens
c'est simple non je me trompe moi je le
ressens comme ça c'est un fait avéré
je vais peut-être demander la ville
claire bretécher là dessus alors est ce
que vous pensez dans et pour le dénoncer
bien entendu oui bon claire bretécher je
ne la présentent pas cellulite tout le
monde connaît ses personnages le nouvel
observateur quant à reiser aussi charlie
hebdo le lui c'est peut-être pas tout à
fait pareil je crois que réserve un peu
le dessin politique le dessin
memory stick plus dans une autre
tradition journalistique ne s avoue pas
changé le dos au monde de dire des
choses et vous le dis avec ce qu'on
aurait main et certains ont écrit au
castello kavanagh
on s'aperçoit très rapidement le fait de
raconter des histoires inventer tout
avec avant de signer n'importe quoi et
c'est sale évènements de ces dernières
années on va pouvoir tout raconté et des
dessins dont je vous ai demandé de
parler un petit peu plus fort je crois
qu'on vous en pente très très bien et je
m'aperçois en vous regardant tous les
quatre vous avez des avis très différent
il ya beaucoup de tendances représentées
je crois que vous êtes 240 dessinateur à
la convention alors comment on arrive
pour la deuxième fois à réunir 240
personnes quand même qu'ils sont pas
forcément des gens qui s'entendent bien
ah non c'est vrai en plus c'est un
ennemi et je suis pour rien ils cèdent
un ennemi tout à l'heure il m'a tourné
le dos c'est pas vrai georges bel où je
vraiment désolé mais je suis obligé de
vous interrompre et pour un petit
problème qui est simplement un problème
technique c'est que non c'est pas un
problème de micro du tout c'est un
problème beaucoup plus gênant si ça
n'était qu'un problème de micro je
serais allé vous aider j'aurais amené
quelques micros il y en a c'est sur
cette table pour vous les a menés
lorsqu'un problème de lumière en ce sens
que depuis quelques minutes
nous le voyons nous voyons très mal sur
nos écrans le visage de de reiser de
claire bretécher de l'osier également de
druyes et nous le voyons très moche
parce qu'ils sont rencontre jour par
rapport à la lumière qui est derrière
eux un petit problème technique qui est
un peu ennuyeux parce que nous avons des
rangées donc nos amis qui sont ici ceux
aujourd'hui et qu'il devait nous parlait
donc de cette convention de la bande
dessinée mais on va les remercier d'être
venu et vous pouvez les voir à la
convention jeu toute façon l'espace
cardin ça se tient jusqu'à ce soir je
crois
et on voudrait invite un jour prochain
alors là vraiment avec vos crayons vos
petits pinceaux jeu c'est clair n'est
pas tout à fait d'accord pour dessiner
en public et surtout devant une caméra
de télévision elle préfère faire ça chez
elle tant qu'ils moi je la comprends
enfin un jour un petit effort la
prochaine fois je vous remercie d'être
venu et je suis vraiment désolé
la technique la est impérative et on ne
peut pas continuer à vous filmer son
lumière ça imprime petits problèmes que
d'ailleurs tous les cinéastes
connaissent bien et que même je pensais
dessinateur connaissent bien il est
difficile de faire du dessin sans savoir
une lampe au dessus de sa feuille
merci en tous les cas d'être venu et
j'espère qu'on se retrouve dans quelques
heures peut-être ou la semaine prochaine
pour en faire quelque chose et là on
vous mettra beaucoup de lumière avec des
petites bougies de chaque côté merci en
tous les cas il me reste quant à moi
juste le temps de vous parler de la
météo
un temps qui devient d'ailleurs assez
maussade sur une bonne partie de la
france avec des orages des ardennes aux
alpes et à la corse des températures
elles auraient tendance à baisser voilà
cette édition est maintenant terminée je
vous retrouve à 20 heures bon après midi